Billy Bob Thornton he stars in season
three of the legal drama Goliath which
begins on Amazon Prime tomorrow that'll
be October 4th so you play a
down-and-out lawyer are you still down
and out in season 3 I'm kind of always
down and out yeah it's you know I have
money but it doesn't stop the alcoholism
and that kind of thing but it's any of
this like do you draw from anything like
this character
were you this character at any point in
your life absolutely you know I mean uh
that's I've told people before actually
that it's probably the closest to
playing myself that I've ever done you
know and he's just kind of a guy you
know even though he was operated in the
big you know sort of law field and
everything for a while cuz he was you
know he was at one point a partner and a
huge thing kind of lost his career and
all that kind of thing but when I go
there every day I mean I I just feel
like the things are happening to me you
know I don't
well you look comfortable going to the
bar not your office is the bar yeah you
look comfortable there and the thing
about it is we shoot the that bar is
called chez J it's been there you been
there yes kind of an institution yes and
I started going there in the 80s so it's
kind of odd to be in there because I
know it so well and it's it's actually
helped to place out I mean the guy who
runs it Mike he said that a lot of
people a lot of tourists come in there
now just to have a drink but did you
have any good men bad memories bad times
in Shea J I had bad times just about
everywhere and it sounds like a country
song
yeah it does but no I I remember because
in the 80s I was you know I worked as an
actor and and played a little music and
stuff in the 80s but I wasn't exactly
what you'd call wealthy back in those
days I in my memory the first time I
went in
JJ was with Nick Nolte oh boy yeah and
it used to be a big hangout they have
pictures on the wall but you know Robert
Mitchum and Steve McQueen you know a lot
of people who went in there over the
years we shoot mostly the exterior is
down there because it's not big enough
really to get a lot of cameras in there
so we've shot inside a few times but
mostly on stage and they recreated it
and looks you walk in the set it's like
Jay Jay is weird I'm imagining that if
you go in with Nolte by the time you
come out it's probably daylight in some
of those situations right I've been in a
few of those he was probably pretty
famous at the time they were you were
hanging with him oh sure yeah yeah but
you know that I just remember him being
there that was at one time and after
that I started going there you know off
and on yeah I mean if you're down in
that area that's kind of a good good
spot to go now you go to big teams that
they have you been to big teams and
Santa Monica Pier right and you are
unrecognizable in Tombstone right you
look like you're 50 pounds more probably
so at least yeah yeah I used to gain
weight for movies but I haven't done it
in a long time I that's back you know
when you're coming up and you think I'm
gonna be you know the renegade actor and
if I'm playing a street person I'm gonna
go live on the street and not take a
shower at all that kind of thing and and
then as you become a veteran you start
to get as comfortable as you can it's
like people always want me to go camping
with them you know and I'm like you know
I I don't want to go camping because I I
grew up in the woods in Arkansas so I
camp for like 20 years
already and I had no choice
and so when I remember first being out
in California and people to say hey
let's go we're gonna go camping and
fishing and stuff I'm like how's this
you guys go camping I'll be at the Four
Seasons you know and I'll you know I'll
come fish with you but then at night I'm
not I'm not staying out there I bit my
mosquitos and all that but do you think
dinero ruined it for everybody because
he he became the part or you know you
look at these guys Daniel day-lewis or
Christian Bale like you got to lose you
know 100 pounds and you got a game you
know exactly Jake LaMotta with zero you
know that's one of the first ones I
remember was when De Niro did that and
which is great you know a terrific movie
and all that so yeah I think maybe he
was one of the first guys who did who
went that far with it yeah but I I'm not
I don't know I've been doing it too long
now to want to learn how to eat soup
with my foot what is the role you almost
didn't take well actually there were two
that I can recall that if I hadn't taken
them it would have been a big mistake I
almost didn't do molesters ball Wow and
I almost didn't do Bad Santa
and my manager who's with me today God
told me
on both occasions you're gonna do these
movies and I didn't want to do monstrous
ball because it kind of seemed like a I
mean just in the brief description and
at first look at the script it's like
why would I want to play a racist prison
guard because you know it's like being
the south anyway and all that kind of
stuff and it took place down there and
he said read it again and I read it
again I said yeah you're right um you
know to look at it in a more artistic
way and see well you know how the
character was really more sympathetic
than you might see on the surface and
then Bad Santa
yeah there's some messed up stuff in bad
Stan oh yeah wait he told me all about
it and he actually said to me before I
read it he said this is either like a
horrible idea or an amazing idea and
what Will Ferrell said that about elf
yeah he said this might be the death of
my career if I knew this right and now I
mean oh it's yeah they're both like
perennial favorites yes I say yes are
you doing to do another Bad Santa that
we did a second one in up in Montreal
where we were actually in Christmassy
kind of stuff because the other one in
Arizona you know she's hilarious and so
like that cactuses up by the kids and
everything but the second we do Kathy
Bates played my mom and it's pretty
funny if you didn't see it I mean the
reason I think the second one didn't do
as well as the first well I mean the
first one became you know like iconic
but the second one I think when you're
trying to recreate something you know
it's hard enough with critics anyway in
other words they they already have an
opinion about it before even make the
movie and so I cringe it's sequels yeah
yeah I usually nervous about it because
I love you know that's why when you so
you know anchorman right and I got
nervous about the anchorman too
I mean if it's still okay but just we
love the original because it's something
we'd never seen before that's right I
think I think that's part of it as the
newness is worn off of it you know for
the second one and but I have to say the
second bad Santa was really good I mean
I liked it and but it was at a time when
and though this was something that
somebody explained to me I don't know
I'm not much on market research but they
were saying that because the movie came
out almost in conjunction with the
president being elected or going through
that process you know the election
process
and people were not in the mood for
crass you know you know situations and
language and you know a guy hears like
this you know drunk profane guy or
whatever you know yeah and that it's
when it's when political correctness was
sort of at its height you know and and
so that was the explanation that I was
given talking to Billy Bob Thornton it's
season three of the legal drama Goliath
which begins on Amazon Prime coming up
tomorrow that's October 4th he plays a
down-and-out lawyer as he seeks
Redemption you're still seeking
Redemption oh yeah you'll never stop
seeking redemption probably not do you
ever do actors drink alcohol in scenes
without like have you ever done that
that does it help you I don't on this
show but I have has no absolutely yeah
there so you thought it did right yeah
exactly like in your mind you go I was
funny what nice yeah sometimes somebody
steps away and goes no you not on that
one and they liked it on that one but
and not everyday obviously but there
there were a couple times so now I had
one or two and there's a scene in bed
set on an escalator and I remember that
day I kind of overdone it did you have
somebody there to catch you in case you
fell well there was this this poor girl
she was a like what do you call it a PA
runner or whatever and she was in charge
of starting the key on the escalator
when they rolled because the idea is the
Tony you know plays the elfin omelet
he's waiting for me and I'm late and all
this kind of stuff and I end up with a
broken liquor bottle in my hand at the
top of the escalator it kind of dumps me
out up there and I said to the girl
because this was in the morning and so
as soon as I got to work I went to work
to work
and so I told her I said look I'm on the
verge of maybe
passing out here and so if you don't
mind just nudge me when they call action
well yeah cuz I'm gonna lay down here
for a minute I wasn't supposed to be
laying down the scene and they started
up the escalator and she couldn't wake
me up evidently and so it kind of dumped
me out up there and I woke up and I'm
like oh yeah
and so I stumbled up there and I've beat
up this plaster jackass and all this
kind of stuff in the scene yeah it
worked out nicely did that make the
final cut I think so I mean I I know I
know a lot of it did yeah I don't
remember if they used the one where I'm
standing on the escalator or the one
where I'm laying down but the part when
I got up there where the Jackass was I I
know that yeah that's in all in there
are you uh are you still a Colts fan yes
yes I am but more of a Cardinals fan
Cardinals yeah that's I mean I'm a
baseball guy I've even got my cardinal
little indignant thing on me right now
you thrown out the first pitch I have a
couple times the the most nerve-wracking
one was when because I was a pitcher and
I grew up as a pitcher okay and you know
and through high school and into the
senior Babe Ruth and you know American
leads and all that kind of stuff
and I actually had a tryout with the
Kansas City Royals and got my collarbone
broken at their camp and I was a jump
pitcher it's pretty good and Tony
LaRussa and all those guys they knew
that and that my hero was Bob Gibson and
[Music]
so in 98 it was the year McGwire hit 70
home runs only and I knew a bunch of
those guys I was down in the clubhouse
before the game and I was gonna throw
out the first pitch they were playing
the Braves and so I was taking a picture
with McGwire
Tony and somebody else is down there
can't remember here and they're gonna
take a picture of us well Gibson shows
up and he gets in a picture with us and
Tony said Bob you're the guys hero why
don't you catch the ball for him to die
and then it's like oh good
[Music]
so now see if they know you're you were
a pitcher or a player at all you can't
do like a politician and kind of roll it
on the grass or whatever and you got to
go up to the mound to the Robert oh yeah
and so here's Gibson catching things so
I thought well you know what I'm gonna
throw him a slider and just see if it
works out because that was one of my
best pitches and I had learned to my
slider out of an instructional book he
had in the 60s that showed you it was
like the Bob Gibson but you can get this
thing it looked like a coloring book
almost it's like a paper book and I had
it and learned all my pitches out of
that book and so if they're in this
slider and it was about probably you
know six inches off the plate is a real
good one yeah and he walks out to the
mound hands threw the ball back and he
looked at me he goes man that's a damn
good slider he goes where'd you get that
and I said out of your book he said my
book and I said yeah you know the one
where it told all your pitches he goes
all that thing like he'd almost
forgotten about it you know and so it
was a nice moment and because you know
Bob wasn't always known for being like
he had a reputation it's not being a
warm guy you know when he pitched that
way
right sure pitched that way and but
after after I threw him that pitch that
day I had several conversations
afterward with him but he loved blues
music and all that kind of thing and so
we would talk about that and he told me
stories about he and Hank Aaron you know
and all this kind of thing is really
nice it's great to see you love the show
it's Goliath it's season three it starts
tomorrow on Amazon Prime great to see
you bill you too thank you for stopping
by
only for Morgan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV
a stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]